welcome back to peers Morganite sensor
and welcome to tonight's Stellar pack
talk TV says to crackling Adrian hello
miss me of course oh look at those faces
ever faces smiled saying yes but meant
no those are the faces um I want to show
a clip this is President Biden most
powerful man in the world the leader of
the Free World you know he always does
weird stuff these days right no look
what he does to this baby who he's never
met have a look at this
all right
oh now this was taken in Helsinki when
he left the uh the summit last week
before he boarded Air Force One but it's
so weird
what man would do that to a baby he's
never met yeah I'm not so I'm not
usually I usually give old people a pass
because I you know they're older and you
have to respect yourself he's nibbling
but a strange baby there is a bigger
issue at hand here which is he just
keeps making more and more gas everyone
can see that he is becoming a bit senile
yeah and you know the Democrats really
need to take this conversation seriously
this man cannot run for it I don't even
I'm sorry I don't think he'll be able to
make it to the next general election I
mean to the extent that he can still
maintain his mental faculties to even do
that I really all these images were
showing him before this is happening
every week
defend the Moon I mean this isn't about
defending him this is about a weird note
this is about querying why it's
appropriate to criticize someone for
being kind to a small human because
that's what all he was doing he was
I don't think kind is the word I'd use
he's literally nibbling a baby
shocked and traumatized
problem with that but clearly the man is
losing the ability to take on social
well that's the biggest he's been
playful no that's fine and we can see
he's been playful because we've all been
there we're a small child
maybe the adults around
we haven't you've all been
focused
it would be if it was an isolation but
if you take it in the context of him
repeatedly falling over yes tripping on
Air Force One falling off bikes all the
verbal gases Relentless even saying God
saved the Queen the other day randomly
nine months after he attended her
funeral it's a it's a procession now a
verbal and physical gaps it's true what
we have is the Press reporting a
prescription
I agree with you and I wonder I wonder
why we have this focus is it because of
his age is it because yes we think that
you're you just cannot stand as a as a
you cannot be taken seriously it's not
about his age it's not about his age
well if it's not about his age what is
it because I know people like Joan
Collins because when he is older and
have a half they've seen half their age
the problem is not his age it's his
condition well he looks to me to be at a
fairly Advanced stage now of senility
and he's the man with his finger on the
trigger okay can we just okay and and
what do we get that information from
that he looks so my eyes and ears that's
your own personal view we're not being
told no no no it's a view shared by most
people by the medics that surround you
feel comfortable that if he wins the
next election he'd be there for another
four years which is six years from now
if that's who the voters voting no no do
you feel comfortable the president of
the United States democracy and that's
what
I don't
let's move on to another age story so
there was a fantastic game at Wimbledon
yesterday yes alcarez taking down uh
Djokovic or somebody put it I think it
was a time today the kid beats the goat
which I thought was great
um and it was a fantastic game obviously
but there was another talking point
which was this guy
oh yes who looked
unbelievably useful right he is 60 in
December yep right and yet he doesn't
look here right so we don't know why
maybe it's a wonder of of something
maybe it's natural maybe it's not who
knows in Hollywood uh but we thought
we'd have a little game which is uh pit
the younger or older right we've had a
two of those well let me know I'm going
to show you some some pictures of people
okay and you've got to tell me whether
the younger older than Brad wow okay
um I'm going to say younger but
definitely looks older I think they're
about the same age Boris Johnson is only
younger by six months than Brad Pitt
okay next
okay next one Governor Ron DeSantis I
think he's younger I think I think
younger he's younger by 16 years than
Brad Pitt look at that yeah yeah
uh next one well I know Tom Cruise I
know he's older same age no he's a year
and a half older Cruise than Brad Pitt
and now probably the most difficult one
of all
actually that's a good question
um wow I mean this is same age
you have to be younger I was going to
say he must be older than you yeah thank
you thank you Paula yeah and thank you
not
I am younger by a year and three months
apparently than Brad Pitt I gotta say he
looks good on it Brad Pitt I've only met
Brad Pitt uh once and it was at the
Oscars I was in the red carpet for CNN
and I shouted out Brad you arrived late
with Angelina when they were still
talking to each other and I've just got
a brilliant picture where somebody took
and his bread just going hey man I like
that that's it that's my Brad Pitt
moment
um literally just said hey man uh but I
remembered it and it was a moving moment
um
talk about well not another man let's
talk about a pyramid of white supremacy
the Church of England is defended
teaching controversial race theories
saying kids shouldn't wait till 18 to
learn about racial justice so teaching
guidance issued by the Diocese of Saint
edmundsbury and Ipswich
is the white supremacy pyramid
at the bottom racial indifference and
jokes and at the top is mass murder the
suggestion being that if you don't get a
grip at your school early Esther you
become rapidly a white supremacist mass
murderer why has this been taught in our
schools honestly it's very baffling and
it's as if the church doesn't have that
there aren't enough social ills to go
around they're not enough issues in
society for the church to address I grew
up as an Anglican and you know looking
at many Anglican churches in sub-Saharan
African Asia in particular looking at
the church of England what they're doing
so the religion is quite worrying I mean
this is really a non-issue and it has
nothing to do with the church of England
I don't understand why they need to
choose politically charged topics to to
try and I don't know further the cause
of British presumption Paula that it's a
bit like when they did the um the the
Gillette reboot and they ditched their
you know man supporting campaign and
basically made if you don't do something
you're all going to be Harvey Weinstein
it's that it's like why go to these
extremities of mass murderers if you
don't deal with your critical race
Theory Career School it's nonsense so I
don't I don't think it is that so
firstly it's not nonsense you've got 30
seconds well exactly and it's not
controversial it's called critical race
Theory remember this is something that
was born out of academics they were
lawyers they were discussing about
Justice and Injustice within
institutions not about not about
individuals and it's the church
attempting to teach about Injustice
that's really important
kids they're going to be Mass murderers
if they carry on I don't agree with you
and I don't agree with that's what
they're being taught peers gotta leave
it there uh we'll come back to that
issue right uh good to see